[Music]
kyle shanahan talking about jimmy
garoppolo the guy who continues to be on
the roster continues to be on track to
be the starter despite everything they
gave up to get trey lance and jimmy
garoppolo comes in
much higher than trey lance on the chris
sims top 40 quarterback countdown he's
at number 21. that would surprise me to
see garoppolo's name ahead of ben
roethlisberger that is stunning to me
yeah well i think listen i think if you
put jimmy garoppolo on the field in
pittsburgh last year you would have got
the same results if not better i i you
know again my my quarterback rankings is
about it's all everybody's playing on
the same offense the same team and here
is my pecking order or my depth chart
that way now jimmy garoppolo listen i
mean we know the number one thing about
him is yes availability but we know he
can execute offense and take advantage
of a lot that's there to be had and help
you win football games and even though
like the talent isn't like top end wow
oh my gosh the guy knows how to play the
game he has a quick release and he's got
very good feel within the pocket for
being a lesser than athlete for the 2021
you know quarterback expectation yeah
he's a true pocket passer there's almost
no
like extending of the play outside the
pocket with jimmy garoppolo but you know
lika brady and not to brady's extent he
can manipulate within the pocket and
move and make people miss and throw the
ball from different angles and things
like that but the reason he's 21 is
because he's not going to deliver you
know a lot outside the realm of the
offense and what's there and put on you
know a platter by the offensive
coordinator so it's a big year for jimmy
g i'm not surprised to hear he's doing
well you know in the mini camps in ota
he's basically fighting for his career
his job everything whether he wants to
be a starter next year all of those
things are dictated on the play this
year so we'll see where it goes
and he plays really well this year and
the 49ers are really good and trey lance
gets another year
on the bench into 2022. you know it's
not inevitable that jimmy garoppolo's
body is just going to fracture into a
million pieces people think that he is
that fragile he played all of 2019
all the way through to the super bowl he
he went wire to wire i mean that there's
a better chance that he'll play all year
than it is he'll miss all year that's
for damn sure so i i just
i i re
i
really think they got freaked out by
the fact that they blew it on patrick
mahomes they blew it last year on tom
brady and they just felt like they had
to do something because they couldn't
rely on jimmy garoppolo and the best
alternative was
keep garoppolo develop another guy
and they just assume at some point over
the next couple of years it will become
obvious that it's time to move from
garoppolo to trey lance and maybe it
won't well i i mean you're right it it
jimmy's gonna have a say in that for
sure and their team is good so he's
gonna have you know a chance to to
really have a a loud voice in this
conversation you know i i still
you know i think you know what you're
saying i agree with i can't dispute any
of that i do think that plays a factor
in the situation and where they are and
those type of things you know i also sit
there and look at you know again i just
think that like whatever you want to
call it just the the the light popped on
whatever where
i think shanahan he's got such great
confidence within his offense and
everything and things like that and yeah
we've gotten the super bowl with matt
ryan and jimmy garoppolo but i think
he's realized too like man i might need
a guy that can just he can make a play
you know extend the play do something to
take the pressure off me from time to
time and i think that's probably what he
saw within the beauty of trey lance and
that's why you know he got that we
talked about it during the year last
year got that firsthand experience of
looking at josh allen going damn we're
playing perfect defense and he's just
tearing us up and that's the thing with
jimmy g we've seen that when the
shanahan offense isn't maybe executing
at all levels and they're not dominating
in the run game and things like that he
is not the type of talent as far as an
athlete arm power
anything like that that's gonna go hey
guys i got it today like we were talking
about desean watson i'll carry it i'll
make plays i'll do things like that no i
mean you see these these are highlight
plays there's a lot of wobblers being
thrown out there it's not a real strong
arm right he's not a good deep ball
thrower but you know in between the
numbers feel in the pocket knowing how
to execute it offense all of those type
of things yes i think he's slightly
better than a ben roethlisberger right
now at this point of his career but you
know there's certainly some question
marks we know that about both guys
the the better garoppolo plays this year
the better the 49ers do the more
pressure it puts on trey lance it's kind
of a jordan love situation not to the
same extent because garoppolo is a far
cry from aaron rodgers but will feel
differently about garoppolo others will
feel differently about garoppolo if he
plays well this year and if the 49ers
get back to what they were two years ago
right week by week game by game victory
by victory our assessment will improve
and there's always going to be this
nagging why did they do what they did
why did they give up the 12th overall
pick and two future first round picks
when they have jimmy g they were wrong
about jimmy g well no because that
injury is always around the corner look
they they they have they have stepped
into a vat of quicksand here that i
don't think they quite realize how deep
it could go and they think these are all
good problems to have i still think the
best problem is no problem yeah no i i'm
with you there and yeah there's there's
a lot of different directions that
this 49er story can go you're right and
some of them there there's definitely a
few avenues of whoa that's not good
that's bad this is bad that's a disaster
hey there's some great ones too i don't
want to
deny that certainly you know their team
is in a good spot but you know hey the
the the the writing's on the wall to a
degree you know i mean yeah the 49ers
you know they've seen what they've seen
from jimmy g and they want more i mean
they told us that this off season they
want more they were kind of telling us
that last offseason you know just only
the brady situation was the only thing
that presented themselves and obviously
they they didn't want to do it for
whatever reason but uh yeah it's it's
going to be interesting to see it is and
jimmy jesus he's a tough one he is for
the fact of not playing uh and all of
those issues it is a real aspect of his
game i mean yeah he played that full
season
two years ago but hurt last year hurt
the year before the super bowl hurt the
year before that in new england and that
would scare me a little bit too if i was
the head coach of a football team
the guy who replaced tom brady in new
england cam newton he comes in at number
20. yeah chris sims top 40 quarterback
countdown he's another guy who has i
know rookie looming 15th overall pick
mac jones the guy that many thought
would be the pick at number three
overall after the 49ers traded up mac
jones has looked good at times in the
offseason cam newton looked good at
times last year i still think the covet
19 thing is what screwed him up right
and they really like him that's why i'm
so confused by the fact that they took
mac jones maybe they just thought we
couldn't refuse a guy who fell into our
laps at 15. they really like cam newton
and i think 20 is a good spot for him i
think he could go up from there this
year if he can stay healthy and if he
can continue his development in that
office yeah yeah i mean we're you know
i'm in the area here with big ben
garoppolo cam newton there's some guys
coming up on the list it's just yeah
there's some question marks you know
it's it's not the easiest placement of
some of these guys you know yeah some of
it is projection and things like that
and feel for you know where they are in
their career and those type of things
piecing things together no doubt about
it yeah they drafted back jones in the
first round but it's new england they're
also always playing chess they're
thinking about years ahead of this and
the and the big pictures of thing also
realizing cam hey he does have an injury
history too you know and you know again
we've seen him get hurt not play the
best last year to where they're
protecting themselves in case it's not
good again you know this year to where
they have something for the future
that's new england but like cam newton's
still good he's still again i think we
have to get in the conversation of stop
evaluating every guy the same through
the like oh the pure quarterback drop
back passing lens no it's 20 21 the
positions changed a little bit everybody
get over it cam newton is like a force
of nature it's not about necessarily how
he picks you apart and those type of
things the beauty of cam newton is the
effect he has on the game the pressure
he puts on the defense that we talk
about so much right and the passing
stats yeah they're not great i get it
you know but when you add the rushing
stats to it 12 touchdown rushes oh now
it's only he's it's it's 20 touchdowns
and 10 interceptions it's not that bad
let alone you know he helped out a
number of different things in that
offense too that will not statistically
be acknowledged you know he helps out
the running game he helps out their
offensive line and here's the last
reason why maybe just from pure
quarterback play he's not playing as
good as jimmy g or ben roethlisberger
okay maybe not maybe they have the edge
there but where they don't have the edge
and even the same stratosphere as cam
newton's presence leadership the things
he brings on the field that we
constantly hear about that new england
is constantly waxing poetically about so
there's obviously something in new
england out there that they see and they
like and last year was a weird year to
your point with the cola and a bunch of
other things so i'm expecting a better
cam newton there's no doubt about that
and let's not disrespect him too much
he's still a force of nature
mvp in 2015 banged up a lot and
i i i think that he can be a lot better
than he was last year yeah take the
patriots a lot farther than people
expect he's got weapons now yes what did
we witness the first few days of free
agency the shopping spree by bill
belichick to address those weaknesses
offensively and and
if you don't have great receivers it
makes it harder to make the offense go
from a passing standpoint so i i agree
with you i like the placement of cam
newton and and i think that that he's
still got plenty of good football left
in him he's only been in the nfl
for 10 seasons yeah i mean that's half
of the time that tom brady's been in the
league let's not wipe away you know what
he did earlier in the year before covid
like he was throwing the ball great
right then everybody was going see it
was belichick it's not brady it's holy
cow we didn't need brady we would have
wanted i mean literally that's what
everybody was saying and then covet hit
and he of course really you know got
flustered didn't throw the ball well
lost his like mechanics his feel things
like that and it became an issue but
here okay here's some other things too
though that i think are like you know
really positives you know we can go
through some games last year
and again there was no room for error
for this team you know the defense was
good but it was not great they had
issues the offense had to play a certain
way to kind of help the defense the
offense also to play a certain way
because like you talked about there was
lack of weapons and receivers and cam
newton didn't have the knowledge of the
offense that tom brady did being in that
offense for 19 20 years whatever it is
so he couldn't take advantage of all the
schemes and things like that but there's
a number of games you can go through
with cam newton and look back at it and
go
and you'll never hear these phrases
attached to his name
he managed and played the game perfectly
like made zero mistakes
and made some plays that of course
helped the team you know i could think
about the jets game you know it wasn't
easy they didn't play well he played
perfect and brought them back to win the
game with like no room for error if they
mess up at all they're gonna lose the
ravens game the week after there's a
number of games where he played the
position really well without a lot of
talent around him and yeah the throwing
there was some some misses there's no
doubt but i just have a confidence that
he'll fix that because i've seen him
throw the ball at a really really high
level a number of times in his career
and you mentioned that leadership factor
i know the patriots believed he was the
perfect guy to follow tom brady a
different style a different approach
right abandoned the locker room and and
gives him an edge to be the starter in
2021 which leads to this question with
trey lance behind number 21 jimmy
garoppolo and mac jones behind number 20
cam newton who starts a game first
lance
or jones i'm i'm going to go with lance
ah man yeah i'm going to go without
injury i'm betting on injury a little
bit
and you know what i think we'll see
lance first anyways because of like all
the things you talked about and the
pressure around that situation
i will at least say i think we see him
on the field first in some capacity a
package to get the fans excited get him
a little experience all those things i
don't know in new england with that
situation and everything there you know
i i don't think we see mac jones unless
there's an injury or or cam newton
really struggles like mightily that way
um so i guess yeah i favor trey lance in
that conversation uh a little bit more
than mac jones
i think it's gonna be mac jones first so
okay we won't remember any of this we
raised these questions about hey what's
going to happen what's going to be this
and then we just move on to the next day
and by the time it ever happens we have
long forgotten the thing we talked about
but that's just kind of the way it goes
for everybody
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports